good afternoon everyone
my name is dr miller and today's lecture
is something
a little bit different but just as
informative
today we're going to be studying a
foundation internal memo from
jean carlisle actus the director of site
81
going forward i will use this
pre-recorded lecture
to quickly educate anyone who has any
questions
or concerns about the anomaly
classification system
this is pretty important stuff so let's
begin
as many of you know we recently
concluded our last classification
reassessment initiative which we have
taken to calling
reclass 2019 the purpose of this project
was to assess how we currently classify
anomalous entities and artifacts
the project was a joint effort between
the american site directors council
the classification committee leadership
group and o57s office
we are grateful for all the support we
have received
the full report will be available in the
coming days but
i wanted to reach out to you and provide
a summary of our findings
as well as some ideas and alterations we
are considering
it is our hope that we have addressed
many of the extant issues with the
current classification format
and we give ourselves room to grow in
the future
so to begin we tasked the team to assess
our current format
and how it is utilized when categorizing
anomalies
after several weeks of research and
deliberation we narrowed it down to
three main
issues number one personnel feel that
the current use of non-standard object
classes is not clearly defined
number two personnel feel that attempts
to obfuscate non-standard object classes
is detrimental to files where they are
necessary
and number three personnel feel that the
object class system does not identify
containment priority or threats to their
well-being
in order to address these issues we had
to take a long look at our current
system
our largest problem as it typically is
seems to be one of communication
and clarifying intent as our
organization steps into the new century
we are met by many challenges
foremost of which is our renewed
dedication to the safety of our
researchers
security personnel academic and
administrative staff
and anyone else under the foundation's
umbrella
as such we determined a more
comprehensive
format was required as such
we'd like to present for your
consideration the result of our efforts
the anomaly classification system
as i indicated earlier the full details
of this format will be available in the
comprehensive report
however i want to take a few short
moments to identify the major
characteristics of this model
to start you'll notice that the area for
item number
classification level and object class
has been fundamentally altered
the item number now features prominently
on the left side of the document
enlarge type font to make sure it is the
first thing
a reader will see on the screen to the
far right is the new classification
system
which we have upgraded to create a more
distinct system
than the one we have now classification
levels remain one to five
however each of these levels is now
named per standard classification naming
conventions
from lowest to highest clearance
requirements
these levels are unrestricted
fully available to all personnel
regardless of clearance
level restricted fully available to all
personnel level 2
or above unless otherwise specified
confidential fully available to all
personnel level 3 or above
unless otherwise specified secret
fully available to all personnel level 4
or above
unless otherwise specified and finally
top secret locked to all personnel
without express permission
or overseer clearance level
below the object number on the left side
you'll see the familiar object class has
been exchanged for a more specific
containment class containment classes
should be used
to specifically identify the challenges
involved when containing an
entity or artifact and do not reflect
some aspect of the entity itself
in addition the classification committee
has agreed to approve the
reclassification
of the five primary containment classes
safe euclid ketter neutralized
and explained with pending as a
transition class
prior to classification these are now
considered static
containment classes and are to be
utilized when there are no extenuating
circumstances involved in containing an
entity that would require clarification
the static classes stand in contrast to
the sixth containment class
esoteric the esoteric class
is a catch-all containment class used
when an object requires additional
containment specifications that are not
present within the five static classes
when utilizing the esoteric containment
class personnel should specify which
containment class should be utilized in
the box below
a full list of applicable colors for
various esoteric classes will be
available in the beta testing guide
shortly
notably this option will not appear on
the module
when not in use you'll notice
the new disruption and risk class
sections
in the bottom center of the module this
is a feature we are currently testing to
try to communicate priority and risk to
our containment personnel
specifically by identifying which
entities are the most likely to disrupt
the general population
where they to escape containment and
what risk those
entities pose to personnel immediately
around them
due to the foundation's resources often
being at a premium
our ability to maximize our efficiency
and safety
will be paramount as we move into the
next century
there are five levels to the disruption
class
scale dark little to no potential to
disrupt the general population
vlam low potential to disrupt the
general population
disruption is typically confined to a
locality
kennick medium potential to disrupt the
general population
disruption is typically confined to a
region or city
eki high potential to disrupt the
general population
disruption is typically widespread
affecting major metropolitan areas
or countries amida
worldwide disruption of the general
population
disruption is global and is a
significant threat to established
normalcy
threats that have the potential to
disrupt an area larger than the
boundaries of the planet earth
fall within the bounds of the immediate
classification
there are also five levels to the risk
class scale
notice the anomaly in question has low
risk potential
individuals nearby may feel minimal
effects from the anomaly
but these effects rarely pose any harm
or even discomfort
caution the anomaly in question has a
moderate risk potential
individuals nearby will likely
experience the effects of the anomaly
and these effects may cause discomfort
or harm
warning the anomaly in question has a
high risk potential
individuals nearby will likely
experience the acute effects of the
anomaly
and will be at risk for experiencing
severe harm
up to and including death
danger the anomaly in question has a
very high risk potential
individuals nearby will invariably be
exposed to harm
up to and including death these effects
are very difficult
to mitigate critical
the anomaly in question has an extremely
severe
risk potential individuals nearby will
invariably be exposed to acute
life-threatening harm
these effects cannot be mitigated
lastly on the bottom right of the module
you will see a new symbol that provides
an
at-a-glance view of the four primary
information sections
within this new system containment class
esoteric class if applicable disruption
class
and risk class these new classification
diamonds will be posted on the exterior
of containment cells of
anomalous entities and artifacts to
provide efficient and
consistent communication of all
applicable challenges
the purpose of these changes are to
provide better communication between our
classification officials and
our boots on the ground containment
personnel however
while we feel this is a major
improvement over the prior model
we understand that there will be those
who do not feel comfortable adapting to
this new format
and will push back against it this is
understandable
and reasonable and since the current
format is still within our standard
there is still no reason to force anyone
to adapt to it
however we will be beta testing this
format at site 81
and so you may see many of the existing
files from our site
change in the coming weeks there are
several other sites who are currently
considering joining us in beta testing
this format as well
and hopefully we will see a wider
adoption going forward
thank you again for everyone involved in
this project
most sincerely jean carlisle actus
director
site81
i hope this was informative and i would
like to thank
every member of staff who is involved in
bringing the acs to life
as i think it will have a definite
positive impact on how we classify
anomalies
it will make everyone's life easier and
most importantly
it will save lives so thank you again
to everyone who is involved
this concludes today's lecture thank you
for listening
if indeed you still are and you are all
dismissed
[Music]
goodbye
i would like to give a special thank you
to
corey barker arbiter soul
retalias karim el ashmoy
professor puffer matthew gilmore
fana matakik eric corbidge
kawaii fire keeper joker corvus
king madding samurai corgis
james saba and
nj vojak if you would like a special
thank you at the end of each of my
videos
and some other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com
forward slash the vogue thank you
you